three two one you won't like me when I'm
angry
[Music]
maybe we try something else I'm trying
to figure out if the Hulk is a hero or
the biggest sex offender in American
history
what happens when the Hulk grows he gets
bigger and what happens to the clothes
he's wearing they typically shred except
for his boxers is that true though is
there underwear on the market that can
support the expansion of those hips I've
been doing some deep research let's say
the Hulk Works five times a week your
average American citizen every single
time that those boxers rip something
comes out you saw the whole thing bacon
cream that's a thousand dollar fine and
that's not it 10 years on the sex
offender list every single year he is
getting 2 600 years on the sex offender
list
is that a hero there's got to be
something on the market that he's using
and we're gonna figure it out so I can
finally get some sleep because I'm so
tired
I'm no scientist but I am a VFX Harvest
and I'm going to use the tools necessary
to get to the bottom of this more
specifically we're going to be using
Houdini's cloth simulation tools to test
the effects of expanding whole Kips on
various types of cloth the first step
was obviously sourcing a Hulk model from
online I managed to find one on
sketchfab that is actually the MCU Hulk
himself which is perfect the next thing
I did was scale the model so the waist
size is accurate to the MCU Hulk based
on numbers I found online then I scaled
him down to match the proportions of a
Mark Ruffalo the problem is
he was still jacked because it's a model
of the Hulk so it's more like a mark
Buffalo so I scaled down the muscles and
made him like a little skinnier it still
looks super weird but don't worry about
it it's science then I can use a very
simple blend shape to Hulk out
essentially from the shape of Mark
rufflow to the full Hulk next I rigged
the Hulk model so that I could animate
him Flex in uh jumping uh strutting man
it's magic and now we have a
scientifically accurate Hulk model that
we can use in our experiments
but almost accurate
there's one more thing
I have to make a wiener
it's important science it's a game of
numbers it's a game of realism if we
can't ground this as much as humanly
possible with correct male anatomy it's
all for nothing I'm gonna have to build
that now oh boy
oh boy
um what
I think I think I just kind of realized
what I'm doing how big do you think the
Hulk is
like like full body mass you know what I
mean oh
yeah baby
that bungee action this isn't gonna work
too long yeah it's just ridiculous yeah
yeah we'll dial it back oh okay tasteful
tasteful scientifically this is going to
get you the most accurate results
fantastic
[Music]
people are seeing what I'm doing
from my screen over my shoulder I
shouldn't do this in this room I'm on
the hoax case for him exposing himself
but in the practice of all this I need
to actually expose him and if I'm the
one exposing him and other people say
then
then I would be an offender
I gotta call Jake Jordan under no
circumstances should you be doing this
in an open office area here you loud and
clear boss I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
I'll just do it here I'll just do it on
your personal computer I'm gonna hide it
uh and while I have you actually uh we
do need a budget for some Underpants I
thought you were doing this all in
Houdini why do you need real Underpants
now I know what you're probably thinking
at home you're thinking hey why don't
you just go online find the tensile
strength of cotton and input that into
Houdini the issue is in Houdini the
numbers are just kind of made up if
we're using 50 000 units of strength on
the constraints of these Underpants what
does that mean 50 000 what units units
dude units of what it could be anything
doesn't mean anything you see Houdini is
an fx software and it was designed to be
art directable not a one-to-one
replication of the real world so if
we're going to keep things scientific
I'm gonna need to do some real world
tests to get numbers that I can put into
Houdini to finally make our simulations
accurate Matt thank you for coming we
have three cloths that we're gonna test
denim there are dozens of us there are
dozens of them cotton he's doing stuff
Tony where's his pants super tight and
of course the Holy Grail spandex spandex
these are the ones we're gonna test I
don't know you're wondering why are you
here there's only one way to measure the
girth of a Hulk which place should we go
should we do Titanic or I almost need to
face you oh don't look at me we're doing
this for science
foreign
I had a feeling that wouldn't work
really wanted to try it anyway okay uh
I've built a device and this is
something that is going to measure the
Hertz girth the hurt the herd skirt I'd
like to introduce you
to the didn't plan that did you
[Music]
now let me show you how it works you
just reach on in here and there's a jack
inside and you just Jack it you have to
make eye contact with me while you do it
I was gonna make the hook expand get
your hand in there
where are we in capacity is that full
girth that's not full girth there's no
way that's full girth is that full girth
that's still girth
so the jack
clearly does not Jack far enough
so what do we do
you guys even work out
hi Jordan Let It Rip but slowly is this
gonna work
[Music]
yes yes that did it ripped we're
scientists ripped we are excited here I
am ripping underwear with them
look at them two little doofuses
wait what is she saying next pair cotton
get to safety do it run run
oh there it is last up last up spandex
all right let her rip did you hear me I
said let her rip right right right right
oh it's it's happening it's happening
it's happening I thought these
Underpants were pretty great but turns
out they're terrible
[Music]
time to put these numbers into Houdini
so the first thing I noticed about the
denim is that the button pops the rest
of it gives way right down the front of
the Cross and then it tears down the
inseam opens the leg up and it's off so
I created a fabric that gives up halfway
down the front first
[Music]
yeah there it is so now our simulated
denim is behaving just like the real
world denim now we've got cotton cotton
has a weak little butt crack so I went
into the butt seam on my virtual cotton
Underpants and pre-factured it re-welded
it together just like seams work in real
life and have given it a break threshold
to tear when it reaches three feet and
the first thing to give up on the
spandex was the waistband actually it
starts to tear down the whites right
around four feet that's what we need to
hit so here we go boom Oh and here comes
that weakness
hey that's good and thank you are we
ready to put this on the Hulk on the
real hulkster uh not yet I do need to do
a little bit more work on the feet
no the what the the little it's been a
couple days now that I've been designing
and setting up this system and
immediately I ran into a ton of issues
we need a piece of geometry that is
growing over time but also being
simulated and also being affected by and
affecting another simulation I didn't
expect this in the beginning but this is
actually a lot more complicated than I
thought I see it when I close my eyes
it's like right there
every time when I blank oh and I'm not
sleeping Daniel
and on the tales of Animorphs
on the tales of mobile game ad
on the tales of John Wick
it does feel like we're progressively
getting weirder in these videos I'm well
aware of it I see the path we're on I
don't know how we got here but there's
land ahoy so we'll keep going
buddy oh man wow thank you for joining
me down here in the secret where we can
finally put this to bed and hopefully
put me to bed because I am
we have tests we have results and we can
finally answer it's the Hulk an Avenger
or an offender first up
denim
amazing
[Music]
full bag and stem oh God a fender dude
I'm glad that was in 3D oh no that's the
way it just spills out oh God him
walking towards camera I'm gonna have
nightmares about that CUNY God imagine
the people who have seen us in real life
yeah no I see I see now this is
horrifying yeah this is what Disney
doesn't want you to see all right Gene's
clearly not gonna work
cotton though what do we feel about
cotton
nobody could get away with it
oh there it is from the behind there it
is
you had to zoom in didn't you this is
undeniable proof that when the Hulk
wears cotton it won't last
it's undeniable evidence these really
just explode off it
and then we have of course spandex
switch you know better than anyone
according to MCU lore is what the Hulk
wears yes that's the running explanation
what Bruce wearing the spandex says to
me is that he's trying to be a better
person he's trying he's repentant
everybody deserves a second chance
and this is Bruce Banners is he an
Avenger or an offender
it's good man yes he is
spandex is your best friend we took him
through a whole range of motion he hulks
out he jumps he walks there's no tear
and that to me is good enough to deem
the Hulk
an Avenger Hulk started as the villain
and he lived long enough to see himself
become the hero those are the stories we
love and that's why the Hulk is such a
beloved character Redemption Redemption
it's the Redemption art
you know I think it goes to show that
growing into something big and weird
isn't inherently a bad thing as long as
you have the right Underpants and maybe
even the right friends to grow with you
oh
if you like this video
you'd probably like the Animorphs video
too certainly made a little while ago
I'm gonna dream of it now go ahead and
click
it's really weird
I can still see the uh penis